if I had to give guys one tip don't be
intimidated and be consistent but people
kind of just throw anything on your face
and especially mad the face wash has
activated silk in it so it pulled off
the impurities but keeps the moisture
then you had a fake and neck moisturizer
so when you rub it in this is a tip
don't use your palm because a lot of it
gets absorbed in your palm use your
fingertips so that that local product
will go on it and not your palm up your
skin as a beauty chunky I'm very
intimidated by that yeah and here this
is also for your neck so you know your
neck and all those things we have the
beard oil keep your beard nice and soft
and then you know this clear shaving gel
one thing that's important for me having
a beard is when you put on like shaving
gels and cream it's like Foams up yeah I
can't see but outline so if you don't
want to shave off everything and go butt
naked you don't have to you can actually
see what you're doing you can prune
accordingly you can prove it according